on March 11th 2020 the World Health
Organization made an announcement in the
past two weeks the number of cases of
Kovac 19 outside China has increased 13
fold Kovac 19 can be characterized as a
pandemic the corona virus or kovat 19
disease had already overwhelmed China
South Korea Iran and Italy and this was
a warning to other countries where it
was now spreading quickly in the days
and weeks ahead we expect to see the
number of cases the number of deaths and
the number of affected countries climbed
even higher the spread of kovat 19 was
no longer something that could be
stopped but we can't still slow it down
you just have to act right now someone
with Cova 19 usually develops a fever
and a cough aches pains and other mild
symptoms are also possible but are less
frequent but the severity of those
symptoms varies and for some people who
get the virus you might never show
symptoms at all based on the data from
China the vast majority of cases are not
life-threatening in 80% of cases people
experience on the Nile disease but in
20% of cases the disease can manifest in
a more serious way but can develop into
quite a severe pneumonia where people
need to be hospitalized and put on
ventilators overall it seems like about
one to two percent of known cases lead
to death but that rate is much lower for
young people and much higher for the
elderly and it also seems that people
with unmanaged underlying chronic
diseases they also have a tougher time
overcoming the virus the virus also
seems to be very contagious more
contagious than the flu all you need to
do to spread co19 is cough or sneeze on
someone else touch a surface where the
virus still lives and then put your hand
in your mouth through your eyes or your
nose after getting infected it can take
an average of five to six days before
you feel sick and your symptoms start to
appear but you can already spread it to
people in that period even if
you feel healthy just as people realize
they're sick they seem to be at the most
risk of passing it along to others
that's how the virus has been so
effective at spreading across the world
so quickly and why the w-h-o was now
calling Koba 19 a pandemic but what they
said next was just as important we
cannot say this loudly enough all
countries can still change the course of
this pandemic and that depends on
something each of us needs to do as
individuals so diseases become really
dangerous when everyone gets sick at
once and the health system becomes
overwhelmed in any Hospital the capacity
to treat patients is limited by how many
beds they have think of this as the
number of beds in your local hospital at
any given time a couple are already
filled by patients receiving treatment
for things like a car accident injury or
a stroke and this dot represents one
person who's healthy and decides to go
out like usual they jump on the subway
and head into the office where they
catch kovat 19 but they don't feel sick
right away and might not for several
days so later they go to a basketball
game where they unknowingly infect two
or three more people most of these
people will have relatively mild cases
but one might be an elderly person with
a severe case who will eventually have
to go to the hospital but these three
who are all infected but don't feel sick
go out again on the subway into the
office and then out after work infecting
several more people 20% of whom will
need to go to the hospital over a short
period of time this process multiplies
the number of people going to the
hospital each day before long the
hospital is full and a crisis begins
people with severe cases of Cova 19
can't get treatment and some who could
be saved died plus people with other
issues can't get treatment either and
some of them die this surge of severe
cases causes avoidable deaths
that's what happened in South Korea Iran
and Italy all of which went from 100 to
more than 5,000 cases in less than two
weeks a lot of people died because they
couldn't get into the hospitals the
surge is made up of only severe cases
but it was generated by people who
didn't feel sick spreading the disease
in public which means the people who can
do the most to avoid these unnecessary
deaths are these people and that means
all of us to slow the virus down you
need to act as if you already have it by
avoiding public transportation the
office crowded places and even small
social gatherings you decrease your
chances of both getting the disease and
spreading it this is called social
distancing if enough of us do it the
virus still spreads but much slower over
time many people might still get
infected but fewer severe cases show up
to the hospital each day never
overwhelming the system
this trendline gets flatter these people
can all get treatment and fewer people
die because of it these are the two ways
the köppen 19 pandemic can play out but
this one only happens if everyone does
their part and it's why experts and
officials are urging people to flatten
the curve by social distancing and
staying home as much as possible it's
also why in the u.s. many companies are
helping by requiring employees to work
from home and major sports leagues have
canceled their games for the time being
it may seem drastic but it's worked
before in 1918 the cities of
Philadelphia and st. Louis were both hit
by a flu pandemic but they responded in
different ways in Philadelphia health
officials allowed a huge parade to go
ahead while in st. Louis officials
prepared they closed schools theaters
and bars
Philadelphia's hospitals were
overwhelmed and many more died as a
result but Saint Louis was able to avoid
those excessive deaths a hundred years
later these are the two scenarios we
face a difference not in whether you get
the corona virus but when you get it
that could mean the difference between
life and death maybe for someone you
know we have to act now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you